I have to admit that it's a lot of fun
when people ask me what I do for my job
because I tell them I literally rub
things together this sounds ridiculous
just rubbin things together but it has a
technical name tribology t RI bo l OG y
from the ancient greek word tri bows
which means to rub it's a funny sounding
word you've probably never heard before
but I promise you discovering it changes
your experience with the physical world
chi balaji has given me amazing projects
I've worked on materials that fly and
I've worked on dog food a combination
that doesn't sound like one person has
any business doing in the span of just a
couple years until you start to view the
world through a tribological lens and I
think you'll be surprised at how
significant a little bit of tribology
can be in alleviating some very large
problems geology is the study of
friction wear and lubrication you have
all experienced all three of these
things remember the last time you tried
to move a heavy object across the floor
and you could just feel something
resisting you that would be friction
friction is the force that opposes
motion where is the loss or transfer of
material it's the reason you have to
replace your favorite shoes because
eventually the soles disappear
lubricants are used to reduce friction
and where they loosen up those stubborn
rusted bolts such as otherwise will not
budge but apology is also defined as the
science of interacting surfaces and
relative motion so interacting surfaces
in relative motion there are a lot of
those in the world as you're sitting
there right now are you looking your
foot at all or maybe shifting around in
your seat because guess what tribology
is happening even the smallest shift in
your seat involves two surfaces moving
relative to each other and your
tribological interaction for the
shift will be different than the person
next to you this is because the clothes
you're wearing change the friction
between you and the see you're wearing
silk it's a little easier to squirm
around on the seat then if you're
wearing wool that's because the friction
is lower for silk if you're moving your
ankle or within your ankle at all to
make a popping sound you've had that
right you get up you move around at some
joint cracks or pops thank you for that
sound tribology that sound can come from
the fluid that lubricates our joints
just moving around you're essentially
releasing gas bubbles and that fluid
that's how it can also come from the
tendon simply moving over each other
pretty common in the ankle so any of my
fellow foot learners out there may
suddenly find themselves curious about
the topology of tendons how does one
become at raballo just like me
stretching you're a kid of course I was
a ballerina growing up I reached a level
where I was dancing on my toes or on
point when you're dancing on point
you're wearing those amazing shoes but
they can be slippery on the stage the
last thing you want to do when you're
trying to dance on your toes is to slip
and fall so we had boxes of stuff called
rosin we would step into the rosin put a
light coating on our shoes Rozlyn comes
from tree sap and in its powdered form
makes things less slippery you learned
real fast as a dancer how much was the
right amount to put on your shoes
because if you didn't put enough on
you're probably going to slip due to the
low friction between your shoe and the
stage best-case scenario you're the
clumsy ballerina on stage but the
worst-case scenario would be an injury
already I was optimizing and
manipulating friction you see I was
destined to be a topologist but you were
also a junior topologist when you used
crayons or colored pencils you knew what
the harder you pressed the darker the
color I also knew that this meant you're
gonna have to sharpen that crayon or
colored pencil more frequently because
it was wearing down faster let's talk
about those enticing shiny waxed floors
that you just had to slide across you
knew if you put on a pair of socks
you're gonna get a really good slide
across that floor good luck trying to do
that barefoot master manipulators a
friction all kids are true biologists
what about us as adults at some point
today you brushed your teeth I hope this
is true biology in action the toothpaste
and toothbrush are working to remove or
where the plaque from your teeth for the
record my dad is a dentist
never thought my career was going to
circle back to the family business but
one day we found ourselves speaking the
same language when I was tasked with
developing a test to investigate plaque
removal sounded simple enough until I
started to look at it as at herbologist
and then I became incredibly complex you
have hard materials those were your
teeth soft materials like your gums the
toothpaste the toothbrush there's
lubrication the form of saliva and water
the dynamics of the person doing the
brushing and more I promise if we put
diamonds in your toothpaste you're gonna
remove that plaque probably remove your
teeth as well so there's a fine balance
to be had between wearing the plaque
away and not damaging your teeth and
gums we're brushing our teeth because we
ate eating is another routine thing we
all do seems simple enough
that's another field of tribology and
it's not so simple you have the food
which will break and wear while you're
eating and that food is interacting with
your teeth your tongue your saliva your
throat and all those interactions are
going to influence your experience of
eating I think you can all recall a
moment where you tried something new you
just found yourself going well tastes
all right I really don't like that
texture topologists are looking at
lubricity coefficient of friction as
ways to connect mouthfeel and texture to
what you're experiencing so that if
we're changing the formulations of what
we're eating and drinking so the sugar
content or fat content are different how
does that change mouthfeel
how do we quantify that this is what
trichologist are looking to solve and
while my colleagues were in one corner
of this lab
get the fat content of yogurt I was in
another corner studying dog food that
lab smelled really good by the way let
me tell you we all brush our teeth on a
regular basis how many of us brush our
pets teeth animals as adults commonly
get periodontal disease so we really
should be brushing our teeth and more
pet owners are starting to do this I
know my best friend is really great at
brushing her cat's teeth somehow good
luck trying to do that with my cat
so what pet food suppliers are trying to
do is incorporate plaque removal things
like treats if you have a dog you may
have observed that you give your dog a
treat and it magically seems to
disappear after just one bite so the
added challenge here is how do you
remove plaque when you have one bite
I developed a benchtop test to study
this problem and to do so I had to mimic
the oral system of dogs their teeth
plaque saliva and I used friction and
wear measurements to study the
effectiveness of that treat on removing
plaque if you're sitting there right now
think about the last time you didn't
brush your dog's teeth you're very
welcome but what's the big deal with
tribology let me give you one more
example no matter where you are right
now you got to this location somehow
maybe you walked or rode your bike but
for most people in this room you
probably came in a car just thinking
about all the tribological systems in a
car you have your personal reactions
with a car the cars interactions with
the road and everything under the hood
and the drivetrain some routine
maintenance is directly connected to
tribology you know how many miles your
tires are recommended for using before
you replace them you regularly check the
treads on those tires you're actively
monitoring the wear of your tires
topology was the study of wear and
friction which hires friction can be the
difference between a safe arrival and a
car accident this is because the
friction between your tires in the road
will influence your acceleration your
deceleration and your stopping distance
as a driver you instinctively already
know how important fiction is because
you know when the roads are wet they're
more dangerous because they're slippery
this is because the water is reducing
the friction between
fires in the road you may recall that
friction is the force that opposes
motion so water reducing that force
means it's now easier for you to move
hence it's more slippery when the roads
are wet something else to consider is
that overcoming friction takes energy so
you're losing energy to friction this is
one way your tires can influence your
fuel efficiency and in fact did you know
that about one-third of the fuel that
you put into your internal combustion
engine vehicle will be spent overcoming
friction one third shivaji researched
has helped us reduce friction and
therefore increase fuel efficiency and
reduce emissions Homburg and armor have
actually done some great studies showing
the impact herbology research can have
on reducing our energy consumption and
they found that looking over the span of
20 years we had the opportunity to
reduce the energy consumption of
passenger vehicles up to 60% we think
about all the cars in the world it's a
lot of energy we can save it's part of
the nearly 9% of our current global
energy consumption that the authors
identified tribology can help us save
there's a significant amount of energy
so when you look at the numbers
geology can do some amazing things my
colleagues have identified up to twenty
quads of energy we can save across the
US alone to put this in perspective one
clod of energy is roughly equivalent to
118 million barrels of oil and tribology
can help us save twenty times that this
is through new materials new lubricants
novel component design doing things like
making wind turbines more efficient and
reliable this happened just by putting
31 people in a room who viewed the world
through tribology lens imagine the
opportunities that will reveal
themselves as more of us start to see
tribology all around my favorite
projects right now aren't aerospace
applications I love reducing wear and
friction in these challenging
environments I can make materials and
parts that will reduce the friction in
moving components and engines so that
they have less force opposing your
motion less force to move means they
require less power so you can use a
smaller actuator
way less which saves fuel I can also
help make parts that last longer through
lower where this will reduce material
waste and also means for manufacturing
the parts less frequently so we're
saving energy and manufacturing I
encourage you to start seeing sri balaji
in the world around you and to think
about how you would improve those
interacting surfaces you experience even
the smallest improvements really add up
chu balaji may be a funny sounding word
but it has a huge impact on our world
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]